so
okay hi everybody thank you for coming
it's great uh just make sure uh you can
ask questions
uh in the slack channel and drag four or
you can do it in webex chat
i'll be happy to answer those probably
towards the end of the talk so i don't
get interrupted
too much uh so hi my name is david i'm
the chief architect of bitcoins
information protection
systems we make cloud security software
and uh not trying to sell you our
systems is just
it's going to be very relevant to this
talk because pretty much everything i'm
going to talk about
uh in regards to distributed
asynchronous microservices
it's stuff that we're either doing or
implementing or trying to do
uh at work and usually my talks are very
grounded in stuff that i'm doing in real
life it's not theoretical at all it's
usually
uh based on in practical things that
we've done
uh so today we're gonna be talking about
asynchronous versus synchronous models
of microservice systems
uh and why you would use one over the
other
what they actually mean what the
tradeoffs are how to think about
concurrency and asynchronicity in stereo
microservice systems
i'm going to keep saying the word
microservices until it's uh or
distributed
so much it's going to lose meaning at
some point for everybody it's just going
to be noise
so yeah let's uh let's dive into it
generally speaking let's talk about what
the difference really is between
synchronous and asynchronous systems
it's not that one is better than the
other app one will make it clear both of
them are very legitimate
uh design patterns and there are good
reasons to use one or the other or a mix
of both
um often times when you build a brand
new system
and you don't know exactly how it's
going to evolve it makes a lot of sense
to use synchronous protocols to
communicate between services
http is of course by far the most common
that's basically the de facto standard
if you want to have micro services
you talk to each other it's usually
going to be some form of http
uh if you need better performance and
less overhead probably you'll do some
kind of grpc version or
there are a few other synchronized ways
for mac services to communicate
uh and obviously the the benefit of that
is it's very straightforward there are
excellent tools
um the observability which means you
know figuring out
when exceptions happen or figuring out
if something went wrong
is much easier because the exception
happens
as part of the call it it's uh you can
find
all of the logged for exceptions in the
same small time space space of time and
logs
and you can handle errors synchronously
in line for example
if you have a web client it will get the
exception immediately to any operations
and you can show an exception to the
error to the user and stuff like that um
and and the failure modes are well
understood because we've had synchronous
systems for a very long time now the
bigger problem with that kind of system
is it introduces a lot of temporal
coupling between different components
and what i mean by that is uh if a
particular dependency of our
microservice system
is currently not available for example a
database is down
where a service is a process fell
and the load balancer has still hasn't
switched over to a different one
then that failure propagates through the
entire system right so if you have a set
of microservices each cold on each other
yeah if you guys could mute that would
be very good uh so if you have a couple
of microservices calling each other
the lowest dependency will if it goes uh
down it will actually take down the
entire chain of services with it
on the other hand uh when we talk about
asynchronous systems
usually there's some kind of queue or
buffer involved between the different
systems
uh so services don't talk each other to
each other directly they talk to some
kind of
message transport or queue and the
component on the other side of that
transport will read the message
whenever it feels like maybe very very
quickly maybe an hour from now and so
a lot of time those would be data right
oriented systems we have to
perform a lot of writes or updates um
and those systems break up the temporal
coupling
uh which means a service could be down
but not affect any of the upstream or
downstream dependencies because
all of those dependencies can continue
working and eventually
one service will recover and process
whatever
few messages were queued up the bigger
issue introduces usually is high
complexity because there is no temporal
coupling
any errors get actually spread out over
time
right so the service went down and it
went down because something that a
different service did that
that is you know three hops away from it
in the microsystem
you might find block messages and spread
that apart an hour or more
both of which let you actually debug
this error uh
but the the uptime or the upside of
actually using aging systems is usually
they're more resilient they're easier to
scale because uh they're
better than they're decoupled better
than uh signaling systems
so that's broadly what we're gonna talk
about and you know throughout
this talk we'll actually dig into um the
reasons to choose one over the other
and some useful patterns uh for
asynchronous systems
and how to think about uh the reasons
for switching
right and so why would you actually go
from one to the other the biggest one is
like i said the temporal
coupling as a
system grows i'm not talking about one
or two micro services it's not really
meaningful there
but for example uh the system i mostly
work on which is proof points
cloud security product we're at over 100
micro services right now and it keeps
growing because we have a large team of
people working on this
it's a very complex system uh and
breaking apart
the temporal coupling between different
services which means if one service goes
down
it takes out a bunch of other services
that depend on it that was a very large
part of why we completely switched from
synchronous modes of communication to
asynchronous ones
and of course scale which is really a
consequence of that
is another the different failure modes
and we'll talk about this at length
is going from synchronous to sickness
basically replaces lack of availability
or system being down
with latency so an operation will
eventually happen
but it's going to take time for the
faults to resolve itself
and of course there are different ways
of doing uh crud
and a lot of the reactive uh patterns in
in programming we have today uh rxjs a
bunch of other reactive frameworks
they're all very strongly oriented
towards asynchronous message
buffering systems right but the biggest
biggest reason of course is breaking up
the temporal coupling
and resolving different failure modes
and for do you understand
really the core tradeoff between
synchronous and aging
systems is let's look at this diagram
let's imagine we have two services uh we
have a client service we have a
server service so to speak and it has
some kind of database or data store
attached to each one of them
and let's imagine the scenario where
where the database goes out
so what happens in the synchronous uh
service versus what happens in the
asynchronous one
in the synchronous service of course the
service that depends on the database
synchronously meaning it writes the
database directly or reads from database
directly
is of course always also down right
because it its own
purpose to exist is to do stuff with
database it's a
sort of a crowd service and so if the
database is unavailable that means the
backend service is also unavailable
uh with the asynchronous model that's
not the case because the html
async service buffers the rights in some
magical place which we're not going to
talk about right now but we will get to
a little bit
but for now work with me let's imagine
you know there's some magic that happens
and the asynchronous backend service
puts its data
somewhere and then eventually it gets to
the database and we'll talk about the
somewhere
uh at length right but just because
database went out doesn't mean the
service is down you can still talk to
the service and
still fulfill its function so right
there we're trading
um some of the consistency of the
service which means it doesn't uh
write write data to the database
immediately it will write it there
eventually
but we're trading it for availability
which means the service continues being
up and functioning
and of course in the async mode the
client service is
always up because again it also talks to
the backend service asynchronously
and so the fact that a database two hops
away went down
doesn't affect just availability so this
would give a much better uh
user experience for example if this was
a ui application
or any kind of service with the
synchronous mode
we're not actually sure what the status
of the client service would be
um it might get an exception from the
backend service
it might also be down if it's a good
application depends how you write it
it might you know hang or throw an
exception so basically
a downstream dependency going down will
strongly affect the entire cold chain of
the synchronous
mode whereas with asynchronous obviously
you maintain functionality
unfortunately what that means is of
course what you're doing is you're
introducing latency instead of an
exception right so you were trading
one failure mode mode which is an
availability
for a different failure mode which is
latency this is going to be at the core
of the reason of why we choose
synchronous over asynchronous or the
other way around
uh what failure modes would actually
prefer and for different applications
different failure modes make sense right
so for google applications where you
want to
if you want to make the error appearance
to the user immediately
you might choose something that is
actually synchronous and then let the
user handle the exception
for standalone applications uh as an
example our system
the proof on casb most of the data comes
into the system
from automated systems from uh some
scheduled jobs which go
to uh cloud providers and bring in
information about user activity
uh and all that stuff is standalone so
there's no person to click okay on an
error message
so all of that in this case we strongly
prefer
to incur latency and just handle the
workload later over the system just
being unavailable and
missing a lot of data because it will
not be repeated right
so that's that's that there there gives
you the reasoning of why you would
choose one over the other
in a client application we will likely
especially for the read path which we'll
talk about a bit later
you will probably pick a synchronous
mode of operation
so that you can actually present the
error to the user quickly and
let them handle it in a standalone
application or something that
receives data that can't be repeated you
will likely choose
uh async modes because they let you
persist data and handle it
after the failure resulted right and so
this
uh really brings us to one of the bigger
topics in usually industrial databases
anyone who's actually done any kind of
work with
nosql databases distributed systems
almost certainly ran across the cap
theorem
um cap theorem which uh was proposed by
eric brewer
a computer scientist from berkeley and
then proven
formally as a theorem a few years later
um
what it says is specifically talked
about distributed databases
but if we think about microservices as
front-ends for different data stores
or just of themselves it can also
somewhat apply to microservices and i'll
explain how in just a bit
but basically the the cap theorem says
for any distributed
database or distributed system uh
it can provide at most two out of the
three
guarantees uh like as follows
consistency so every read from the
system
receives the most recent uh version of
the data
or an error so if you can imagine uh
if it's a service that runs a database
you write something into your database
you read it back immediately and you get
the version you wrote
availability which in this case means
that every request to the system
receives a valid
non-error response right it doesn't have
to be current it doesn't have to be
updated
but it has to get in the response that's
not a timeout or an error
that that's the definition of
availability for cap theory
and partition tolerance which means that
the system can continue to function
despite losing an arbitrary number of
messages or delaying messages between
network nodes
now if you think about modern systems
the real trade-off here
is always between consistency and
availability because
a system which doesn't have partition
tolerance a distributed system without
prediction tolerance
is not really a practical production
system right if you don't if it
has an undefined behavior uh because it
loses network packets or messages
that system is not robust and you're not
going to really put it in production so
for practical purposes in real life
we get to pick between a system that's
either petition tolerant and strongly
consistent or
some kind of consistent or it's position
tolerant and
highly available but not both at the
same time
now notice that the word at the same
time here is very important a system can
be
one or the other at different times and
flip between those two according to
exceptions or configuration
uh but at any given moment uh that's the
way it works so uh
to demonstrate it um i usually do this
in
in person so it's usually a quiz and
people can raise their hands and stuff
so we'll see if this works virtually so
think about a bank machine an atm
or whatever uh it's called in english um
you go to a bank there's a teller bank
machine at the wall you want to withdraw
some money
and there's three different machines
right and just as you go through
withdraw money what happens is the bank
loses network connection to the main
computer the mainframe
so uh now this atm doesn't have a
network connection and you try to
withdraw money what's gonna happen
right so one of two things is going to
happen either it will let you
withdraw some money but then it won't be
able to update the backend system until
connection resumes
or it will not let you withdraw any
money which means either it's an
available system
and then you can continue using it and
you get a valid response in this case
the response
is money or it's a consistent system you
go to it and you receive and uh you
don't get the latest result you can't
update the system
but you uh but it doesn't actually
create an inconsistent
inconsistency between the mac machine
and your actual bank account so who
thinks
banks would put up a consistent system
for atm machines
raise your hands i can't see you but you
can raise your hands see one person
thinks
excellent thank you very much so who
thinks it's actually going to be an
available system which means they will
prefer
um user experience to let you continue
using the bank and withdrawing money
over consistency
anybody okay so uh so i can see how many
people at one person i saw one person
book but i can see the rest of you
so i'll just tell you the answer for
most
banks and again it varies with the
different countries and there's some
regulations which
affect it but for most banks they will
actually prefer to let you withdraw
money
so an atm which lost network
connectivity will still dispense money
up to a certain limit
the the limit obviously depends on what
kind of uh account you have and what
bank and stuff
but it will let you keep growing money
um
of course it doesn't really happen very
often in real life how often does a bank
with network connection but a long time
ago it used to happen quite a bit
um and there were actually very famous
attacks on banks where a person was able
to to
disrupt the network connection and
withdraw money from a bunch of machines
in a row
um but normally what will happen is
you can withdraw money if if it means
that your bank account will go negative
that's actually not a bad thing most
banks will let you go into a negative
balance because they can then charge
your interest on the negative balance
and it's for the
to the bank's advantage and so they
prefer uh user experience over
consistency
um but that that's just to demonstrate
the trade-offs you make in
consistency availability and if you were
to now design a bank machine system with
microservices
you would have to think of what do you
do in every failure scenario in this
case all right
so that's that's broadly speaking the
cap theorem and the way it applies to
microservices of course is again um we
have to split up
the read path and the right path so when
you write your system
um if you want the read which means you
have a ui application that's very
important for it to be consistent
you might choose a synchronous system
which will go and update a database
and then if you refresh the page or
somebody else uses this
information it will be available
immediately it will be consistent with
whatever you wrote
uh versus an available system where you
will possibly queue up or buffer
right to the system uh and so if
you can't write at that moment they will
eventually get written
but that means that uh the user or
whoever reads the data
will get an inconsistent a stale view of
the system okay and that's
that's our trade-off right and so i keep
saying
queue up or right to this magical place
without explaining what a magical place
is so it's time to talk about
where would you actually put it it's
obviously not another secret and i'm
sure everyone thought of it
they're we're all familiar with cues and
various
message transports um but overall and
i'm not
going to talk about a specific vendor or
specific technology they're broadly
uh we'll talk about use cases and broad
categories of
cues but not you know if specific
technology
um but broadly a systems asynchronous
system designs
assume that the message transport they
use to send messages between services
is reliable and robust this is like the
journey level secret
each of the systems aren't inhere
inherently more highly available
it's just you move the availability or
the the failure point
to one central system which is your
message transport
and then you put a lot of effort into
making that as robust and available as
possible
instead of making each individual
service or each individual component
as robust as possible so overall if your
message transport goes down
the entire system is still going to go
down right unless you build some kind of
hybrid very complex system
which is not something i've ever seen in
practice in real life
um but yeah you have to assume that the
message transport is reliable
which means talking to it is consistent
or at least
durable unless of course data loss is
acceptable
and that's not a joke there are systems
where data loss is actually perfectly
acceptable
systems that look at for example the
latest snapshot
is the state of data or statistics for
example think about
the trivial example is stock ticker
right i don't care usually
uh to show the history of all the stocks
i want to see the lightest price
and if i missed you know five or six
updates i'll just show the next update
and it's fine right so there's going to
be a slight delay and so in that case
asynchronous lossy system is okay but
for most
practical applications when you're
thinking about your real world
production systems
data loss is not really acceptable and
so we kind of have to assume that
message transports are
and this is actually true for most of
them because almost every messaging
technology
that's you know used in use and popular
today
has built-in redundancy and replication
and a lot of features
around guaranteeing uh durability and
and you know
reliable delivery of data a lot of them
are
sas systems right so if you're on kind
of public cloud every single
public cloud has their own offering or
multiple offerings really amazon has
kinesis and sqs and sns
and azure has event hubs and google has
a thing which i can't remember the name
of but every everyone offers one of
those
and all the big vendors have their own
cloud offerings so
if you're building a new system you
don't really need to put in that much
effort into making it
available you can just buy that from
someone obviously by paying lots of
money
um so uh that let's assume that our
transport is in fact
available and robust and let's talk
about what we can do with it right so
now that we've
sort of established that in the case
where we want our system to be
asynchronous or some part of our system
to be a certainness
and we will later on talk about how to
make a hybrid
synchronous versus asynchronous system
and where it makes sense
there are some patterns which help us
just like there are design patterns in
coding which
which cover a lot of common use cases in
asynchronous
messaging patterns there are standard
design patterns
which you can apply to your system it
will go through them real quick
the easiest and most uh common is fire
and forget
is where you post a message to some
queue
you don't expect a response and you you
do
if you want the transport to be reliable
you do response i expect an
acknowledgement
from the transported senate itself but
not from whoever receives the message on
the other side
so in a trivial example uh so at
proofpoint we use kafka for
most things um so a kafka producer what
it does is it writes a message to
a topic and then it commits
the uh then it waits for the topic for
the broker to respond and say that yeah
it's message been durably committed
and only then it moves on you don't just
move on and assume the message has been
passed but it doesn't wait for the
acknowledgement from whoever consumes
the message on the other side of the
queue
because that's not far and forget that's
the next pattern we'll talk about
um so that's actually very useful most
of this is very useful
in data processing pipelines uh so again
the products i worked on a lot uh the
proof from casbi is
basically just a giant pipe which moves
data from one side to the other and does
various different transformations with
it along the way and it's built just as
a series of
these kind of drawings we have a service
which gets data does something with it
puts it in the queue but on the other
side of the queue a different service
which gets the data does something puts
it in a different queue and it doesn't
expect a response back and it doesn't
send anything back
data just moves downstream from one to
the other until it reaches some end
point uh usually a database
right and so this is this is by far the
most common most useful pattern in hdmi
communications we have
um it's also very robust because again
uh
there are very few dependencies every
service only depends on the message
transport itself it doesn't depend on
anybody else or any other response
and there's actually very little
coupling between components uh the
biggest downside of course like with
most certified system here is debugging
it
because if you expect service a to send
something to b
and c and d and you know however many
letters next
uh if the message doesn't uh get to the
end
figuring out where it went away or which
service lost it
is very much non-trivial especially if
there is latency in the system
uh we'll talk about this towards the end
of the talk uh and expand on it but if
there's latency in the system
uh there might be two error messages
produced by two different services
and they're not actually uh in the same
time frame there might be a lag of
an hour between two services and so
while we'll log an exception an hour
later from the other
and how you find those and correlate
those is a very complex problem
which we will answer in the stock so the
next pattern is publish a subscriber
it's it's just an upgrade of the
previous notification pattern
um where fire forget is between two
components
uh pub sub publishes subscriber is again
a very well understood pattern
everyone i'm sure used it at some point
in their lives either
between threads within this in a single
process or maybe between processes
uh is where one or more components
publishes a message
and then multiple components subscribe
to receive those kinds of messages
right and again there's no expectation
of a return message it's still
kind of a fire and forget pattern the
biggest difference here is of course
um that you can configure whether
all the subscribers receive the same
message or a single subscriber receives
a
copy of the message there are lots of
variations they're all very useful in
their
way and the biggest difference here of
course is whether transport is durable
or transient so transient
patterns would be something like the
default mode of rabbitmq
and a few others notification systems
where you send a message and anyone who
was listening to
that message at that moment moment in
time
will get the message and anyone who
missed it will miss the message
and that's that's fine for uh as an
example of the previous uh example we
had
stock ticker we send the update anyone
who got it excellent anyone who missed
it
it's fine it's no big deal for more
robust production systems of course you
want durability in the transport
you want a subscriber who went offline
and came back
to be able to catch up and get all the
messages it missed while it wasn't
listening
and so you would have some kind of
durable transport instead of just a
message broker that just sends the
messages forward
right but either way it's a very useful
very down pattern
we use it again a lot because it's just
a logical extension of the notification
pattern
uh if we have some kind of message let's
say a user performed in action
and we have three different services
which are interested in that kind of
message
one service goes and updates the user
profile another service goes and runs
heuristics to analyze
the activity and the third service goes
and does something else
they all care about this message they're
independent of each other so in this
diagram c d and e don't rely on each
other each service will do
an independent thing with the message it
receives and so it makes perfect sense
to decouple them temporarily because
we don't want the state of one service
to affect the availability of
all the others so this is where we would
use this kind of pattern uh makes a lot
of sense
um the next one and this pattern uh is
what
most closely mimics known uh synchronous
patterns
which is request response um it's the
best analog we have
to for example a synchronous f2 a
space synchronous http request where you
make a request and you wait for a
response and you expect something back
um of course in an asynchronous system
that can take an arbitrarily long amount
of time uh
but the pattern is servicea sends
something to service b
service b does something with this
message and then returns a different
message
to service a the biggest difference
between
the synchronous version of this pattern
and the asynchronous version
is in the synchronous version
usually the service which originates the
request
maintains the context of the request in
memory in the thread
for example if you think about the
standard http service it calls
another microservice gets a response
back you still have
the object which you use to create the
response in memory so you can handle the
response
in the same thread you don't need to
store the context somewhere else
when it's asynchronous we have multiple
instances of service a we have multiple
instances of service b
let's say a1 posts a message service b1
receives it
posts a message back but then nothing
guarantees that service a1
that instance will receive the return
message a different servers will pick it
up maybe a3
and a3 doesn't share memory with a1
they're different instances they're
different processes
and so you have to handle this
propagation of context if the return
message
only makes sense if the response makes
sense only in the context of the request
how do you propagate the request back to
the service aid which received the
response
right so there are multiple ways but
they both basically they boil down to
where do you store the state you either
put it in some kind of database or
somewhere which
has its own tradeoffs because now you're
introducing a synchronous
a space synchronous dependency for
service a because a has to first
store the message with the context in a
database
send the request get the response get
the context
synchronously from the database and
merge those two and so you're kind of
breaking
uh away from the sms pattern or the more
common but slightly more expensive
version is
you send the entire request with the
contacts and everything as part of the
message and then service b
has to return its response and the
request or the
request context together with the
response and so in this case
the response travels back and forth
you're sending more data
it's sometimes it's practical sometimes
if it's too much context
it's just impractical to do it's too
expensive it's too large it doesn't fit
but that's that way you avoid any kind
of synchronous dependencies
right and so in our system it's
about half and half between those two
use cases we do have cases where
we get a large message just just an
example um one of the features we have
is
a data link prevention so we download
the file
and then we need to scan this file and
classify the data is it
a pii private data or classified data
and stuff like that
so we download the message but the
message is large it could be 20
megabytes of file
we're not going to send the entire file
over darkest kafka
it's just not practical so what we'll do
is we'll store the file in some kind of
shared file system
we'll send a message with a pointer to
the file to a different service
which will use the file do some stuff
put the response
the blob of response somewhere else send
the message back saying the response is
ready
and here's a pointer to the response
right so this mixes
synchronous and asynchronous modes there
are obvious downsides to it
but it's just a practical reality that
we couldn't make it work completely
asynchronously
we had to compromise and make it half
and half in many other cases
we send a we send the request and
persist the context on the request and
that's obviously preferable if it's
practical to do so
right so the next next expansion of the
same concept of course is the
distributed blog
which is just another way of saying pub
sub
but you don't have to sub which means
subscribe
to the tail of the queue right this is
the way
a lot of the popular services work
kinesis kafka
pulsar most of the message logs
that have memory let you actually
consume messages not from the
top of the queue but from any point in
the queue and they have a history
potentially going back days or years
however long you want
of all the data that's ever been logged
in this message log
and that's why we call them different
things so you sign a message queue it's
usually a distributed
log because you have a log of all the
messages and a lot of time you also have
some kind of compaction feature which
will uh
duplicate similar messages right and so
this pattern is extremely useful for
data processing applications
or for just being able to reprocess data
very quickly
one very strong use case for this is
we have a service which maintains user
profiles
uh what it does is it gets information
for about users
from directory services things like
title name blah blah blah
and then it tries to figure out if that
user is an executive or not
according to their business user user
and the title there's a lot of
natural language processing on the title
and the business unit
and tries to figure out if that person
is an executive or not
for us the reason is an executive
is a more vulnerable to secure attacks
and we have a security system
so we try to figure out and classify if
that person is more vulnerable or not
um and so this algorithm has gone for
maybe 50 different versions
um and so we have a data store of maybe
hundreds of millions of users
we know about and so every time we
roll out a new version of this algorithm
what we want to do is
obviously put it in production so that
any new updates to the users come in
through the new version of the algorithm
but we also want to go back
and reprocess all of the old messages
and update them because now we can
calculate
whether they're an executive better than
before but we don't want to have down
time in the system we're not going to
just
stop everything put up the new version
in production and let it run and then
accumulate new messages
what we normally do is we spin up a
second version side by side
with the same with the old service and
we point the
updated version to the end of the queue
of user updates
and let it start consuming and usually
takes a day or two it goes through the
entire log of all the users we've ever
seen
and it keeps updating the database at
the same time the old version still
works and still running the old version
of the algorithm
on the real-time data eventually the new
version catches up to the log and then
we bring down the old service and only
the new service remains in production
and so we do the switch over between two
different algorithm versions
uh in real time without losing
functionality um and so
and it's completely seamless right so
that's a very strong use case if you can
map it to any kind of
stream processing you have it's probably
going to find some use there
um and it works basically the same way
right you have uh
one or more publishers and however many
subscribers
and the benefit of course is that any
subscriber a new subscriber can join
and find all the messages that ever
existed uh if it wants to
and we'll talk about this in just a
moment a bit more when you talk about
the pen source
now they have all these basic
communication patterns right we can
start combining those into more higher
level patterns
and the biggest one and i think probably
by far the most useful when you build an
asynchronous system
is cqrs which is command query
responsibility
segregation or separation which
it's a very large topic it could be a
talk in and of itself but to summarize
it into
three minutes um very often um
in traditional architectures we use the
same data model
to both update a database and to query
from the database
if you think about it as an example
let's say we have some kind of user
object
we have a table of users a user update
comes in we write the user we want to
show that if you want to show it in the
ui
we do select on table and star from
table users hopefully nobody does select
star please use
for the full uh attributes select star
is a bad practice but
roll with me and so we use the same
model to both update
and get the data from the database now
at large scale or the complex snap
system when you have a large enough data
model
that doesn't work very well because
oftentimes the model we want to read
is not the same as the model we want to
write to the database
for example again our example we have
the user store system which aggregates
user profile information from hundreds
of different directory services
a user object in our case has
many many sub-objects it has a bunch of
information about virus accounts
it has history information about what we
saw about the user it has
uh all the profile information uh
a bunch of different subcategories each
one of those gets updated separately
if we were to model this in a normalized
way it would be maybe 50 different
tables that we have to all join together
but we once we wanted to read this user
we don't care about all of that
multiple model stuff we want just one
giant user object because we want to
optimize the system
for high for low latency high throughput
reads in our case
the third generation of our user
management system
has uh at speak about a million requests
per second to it
right but pretty much every other
subsystem in our
our product calls to the user system to
do something with it and
it's a crucial piece of the
infrastructure and so it needs to serve
a million requests per second
um which means you can't do a million
joins on 50 different tables
and so in our case what we do is we
write one kind of model
to a message log then we have some kind
of
process which takes all these model
updates it
transforms them and that creates a new
reador in the model
and stores that in a different database
that's actually a key value for
the reads or in the low latency key
value store
and that's the right path of the cqrs
right so usually in nctrs what you will
have is
an asynchronous write path where you
queue up a bunch of updates
you run some sort of domain logic on
them and create your right model from
those
there'll be some kind of change
notification which will create the read
model
and the read model is queried
synchronously because often times
uh in almost all ui applications and a
lot of other types of applications
the read path in the system it makes a
lot more sense to make it
synchronous uh it's actually very hard
to imagine for example an application or
a website
where the read is asynchronous where you
queue up the read and then
your client waits for it and gets the
data and then presents it or something
that
it just makes so much sense it's easier
easy to debug you just have a
synchronous request to the read path but
the right path it's obviously much more
scalable and much more robust if you
make it html
right and so for the qrs uh if you look
at all the panels we talked about
it makes perfect sense to have some kind
of message log as your
command queue you have some kind of
consumer which will take it and create a
new
queue of write data models some kind of
persistence layer
which takes updates from the right model
again as a queue into the read model
and only then there's some kind of
service which serves it so
our version one of our system was almost
entirely synchronous
and one of the biggest problems that we
had was
the two conflicting load types on our
user identity system
where we had spikes of writes whenever
we updated the database
and a consistent stream of reads from
the same database and
every now and then because the reads are
constant but rides are spiky
it will just overload the system and
fail most of the reads and then the
website will become unstable
and one of the first things we did was
actually separate the component that
reads data
from the component that writes data to
make sure they're actually independent
from each other
that's a big uh part of why you would
actually consider using cqrs in your
system
that brings us to event sourcing because
they're they're often used together
event sourcing is not necessary
necessary for cqrs but very often you
will
actually use them together what event
sourcing does is
it's a pattern where instead of storing
the latest snapshot of data
you store all the possible updates of
that data right and so for example
in our case uh the system i talked about
earlier which calculates
the user uh the user type according to
their title
we do store all of the title updates for
every user forever
so that we can run over them and
reconstruct the system
if it ever goes down or if you need to
recalculate with the algorithm
so if you imagine there's let's say an
infinite table of
key value key value pairs
where the key in this case is a and b
and the value
is some change you need to make on the
object your materialized table right
your
let's say a sql database would be just
the final version of it which is
applying
whatever whatever uh operation you had
although the queue
but your event source your own store
would have all the possible events
a classic against example of this which
is almost never used but it's always
uh talked about and then blogs and talks
is
a shopping cart let's say you go to your
ebay or amazon shopping cart you put
something in a shopping cart you put
another thing in shopping cart
then you delete something because you
don't want to pay it and
eventually what you pay for is just a
snapshot your latest version of the
the shopping cart but the vendor
actually cares very much about all the
changes which happened to the shopping
cart
because they might if you put something
in there and you take it out they might
want to
try and sell it to you later and send
you some ads because everybody loves ads
and vendors love selling ads
and so that's a perfect example of event
sourcing
right so uh if you take all of those
together um
we get basically uh full coverage of all
the various patterns that are very
commonly used in http systems
most of them don't really have a
synchronous a space
synchronous analog right except for
request response which is
obviously very straightforward that's
not because this is
again there's necessarily something
better or worse about synthesis patterns
it's just
syntax patterns are much more
straightforward uh and so
there's fewer patterns we need to cover
um
now that we have patterns we need to
talk about delivery guarantees which is
something we ignored
for most of the stock we assume that the
message transport is magical
but the thing is it's not magical
message transports fail quite a bit
and so understanding what delivery
guarantees you get from your message
transport
is important in order to implement every
possible pattern because
how can you for example implement event
sourcing if
you're not guaranteed that every message
will reach the destination
if your event sourcing relies on
applying every operation and you miss
two of the messages
the result is going to be incorrect um
and so there are
broadly speaking there are three
delivery guarantees we can talk about in
the messaging system at most ones which
means
every message will be delivered to the
subscriber consumer whatever you're
going to call it
at most once which means it might be
zero times or it might be one time
let's think about the kind of
application again we can go back to the
stock ticker
stop ticker is a classical example but
most ones it's a lossy system
it's guaranteed that you will get each
stock tick
at most once but you can you might skip
some of them
um there are there are some practical
uses for that kind of system
uh again most mainly statistics based
applications or
things just need to show a snapshot ui
based applications
uh what we're doing right now video
streaming if you think about
you're seeing me if you if your network
skips a few network
packets or the video or the audio it's
no big deal it's not going to be
noticeable
so video and messaging uh delivering
passwords are at most once
the most basic internet protocol which
is udp is of course in its most
low state pattern right the up to that
is at least once
you're guaranteed that every message
gets delivered at least once which means
it can
be delivered most more than once this is
by far the most common pattern
in message cubes we'll get to exactly
once
in a bit it's kind of a bit of a unicorn
but in practical terms
most message queues designed today have
at least one delivery
which means you're guaranteed to get
every message you're not going to lose
any data
but it's very likely that you'll get
some messages more than once
depending on how you set up the system
and you know stability and various other
considerations
you might get a lot of messages more
than once um
this has two implications one if we're
building asynchronous systems
with at least one's guarantees we have
to consider it in potency
every service has to assume it will get
the message more than once
and if you have side effects from the
service side effects being
you write to a database you send an
email notification you do anything with
the message
you need to consider how to make it as
important as possible it's not always
possible as an example we have a
um we have an alerting system in our in
our product
which if some user performs malicious
activity
it sends an email to the administrator
an email
is not important right you can't take it
back you can't you know if you send it
again you'll send another email
there's no way to overwrite an email
because you sent it and it's a side
effect that happens and it went away
but for most other things things like
writing to a database
we do our very best to model data in a
way that if you
apply the same update more than once it
will not change the final result
this has very important implication on
things like counting on stream or stream
statistics right one of the
uh most uh let's say least understood
and
and things were let me put it this way
have you ever had a product management
manager or someone come to you
and say oh let's do this it sounds easy
i would just count all the items in the
stream
i had this happen a year ago where
[Music]
someone wanted to know how many
activities we had in a day
in our system how many activities in the
stream it's roughly about a billion per
day
uh and so we went and said okay we'll
need to build a business system which
can do you know bi analytics on a
billion items per day which means we
have you know
300 billions of those per year it's
going to take a couple of weeks
to build something like that and say no
but why don't you just count every
message
you see every message just count them
but that's not
does not work the way it works you might
skip some messages you might
send some messages more than once
counting a live stream is an extremely
complex engineering problem
almost certainly you will over count
depending on how you store the counter
in memory on a state you might under
count
it's almost impossible for you to count
exactly
um there actually and uh we're not gonna
have this
time for this new talk but there are a
lot of probabilistic algorithms
which can very efficiently do things
like counting and statistics on a stream
of data
and give you an approximation um in a
constant amount of memory so look for a
probabilistic data structure it's a
fascinating topic
but you know it's the topic for for next
year's talk
so as i said at least once delivery
if you for example try to count messages
in the stream
it's very likely that some messages will
be repeated so you'll over count
uh within at most one one system you'll
probably under account
examples of why at least one systems
exist let's think about things like
kafka or kinesis or pretty much any
message queue the way it works is when
you consume a message
the consumer gets a message or a batch
of messages does something with them
and then it needs to send an
acknowledgement to the transport saying
i finished with the messages
if the consumer process uh crashes
before it sends the acknowledgement
the next time it goes up it will get the
same messages because they weren't
acknowledged
and depending on the different flavors
on transport it might be one message it
might be a batch of a thousand messages
or a bulk of whatever is right um
exactly kafka because i'm most familiar
with kafka
has two different modes the standard
kafka consumer reads a batch of messages
up to a certain size and you acknowledge
the entire batch all at once commit the
options for the batch all at once which
means
if you fail to commit the offset but
you're still processed most of the batch
next time you'll repeat all of those
messages again
with kafka streams there's a single
message acknowledgement so acknowledge
every individual message
so you will repeat at most one message
but you will still repeat that one
right and so the goal in unicorn is of
course why can't we have exactly once
delivery
uh and the answer is we can in very
specific very narrow circumstances
and the circumstances are if you don't
have
any side effects and if you are reading
and writing messages
from the same message transport and the
message transport supports transactions
then you might have exactly once message
delivery
so to narrow it down to a practical
scope uh if you have
if your system reads from one kafka
topic
rise to a different kafka topic on the
same kafka cluster
and all it does is change the message it
doesn't do side effects it doesn't call
any other external systems or databases
then what it can do is it can commit the
offset
for the consumption and the production
at the same time
and then if the process crashes then the
outgoing message
also won't be committed and the incoming
message won't be committed
so in those narrow circumstances uh you
can have exactly
one message delivery if you change any
of those variables
it will no longer be exactly once
because for example if you
call to external database to enrich your
data along the way
uh if your process crashes it comes back
it will get the same message
but the external system you call to
might have changed in the meantime so it
won't be
important uh if you need to read the
message from one transport and write the
outgoing message to a different
transport
uh there's no way to make a transaction
between those two you have to commit the
message first
then you can crash before you commit it
in the output message and so you have to
uh yes you have to break
which means you have to change the order
around you will commit the outgoing
message first
then you will commit the consumed
message offset
uh but then if you can't crash between
any one of those two lines
you will get the message again so
basically pretty much changing any
parameter in that specific scenario
bring this either to at most one's
delivery or at least once delivery all
right
and so i don't think it's a practical
goal to chase i don't think it's
important i think both systems can be
practically made to work well enough
with at least once delivery
and in some cases at most once actually
makes it
so that of course brings us to
transactions right because i mentioned
transactions uh just earlier
uh we won't be won't have kind of time
again it's a whole talk in itself
there's
a lot of literature about distributed
transactions but i'll run through this
real quick
uh just to have a sense of you know how
complex of a beast we're chasing here
um so unlike standard synchronous
single node systems where transactions
are easy so to speak
because your database or wherever else
gives you transactions for free
distributed systems are very complex and
transactions just don't work very well
across processes
so there are a few ways to provide some
form of transactionality
in a distributed async systems
for the first one is a two phase two
phase commit to phase commit is a
distributed protocol that is synchronous
it relies on being synchronous
and i'm not gonna go into the delays of
the algorithm
but basically it breaks a large atomic
transaction into a series of steps
where every step is uh unique and you
can
if the transaction fails in the middle
you can recreate and either continue
from the previous step
or roll it back it's very complex it's
usually impractical to implement for
performance reasons because
it takes a lot of operations we won't go
into it
but for our purposes for asynchronous
systems there are a couple of very
useful transactions one is called
the saga and the transactional outbooks
and those go together
so transactional outbox is a very common
uh
use case in asynchronous systems imagine
you have a service which gets a message
uh does something with it puts the
result in a database
and then sends an outgoing message right
um and what you want to do is
you only want to send the outgoing
message if you succeeded in updating the
database
for example uh something that we have a
lot of in our system
updating a cache we get a message we
want to process the message
we want to update an in-memory cache
which is a separate process
and then we want to post the result to a
permanent store as well
for example in our case 2s3 right and so
we want to update a database
and send an outgoing message as a
transaction if we fail to update or for
the cash we don't want to send the
message if we fail to send the message
we don't want to obey the cash because
that would cause an
inconsistencies in the system and so
this only works again in a specific case
where you can split
the operation of updating the database
and sending a message
into choose two steps uh imagine you
have a database with
two tables one table is the entity table
the other table is let's call it an
outpost like a message outbox table
if you can transactionally update both
tables you update the actual entity
table
and then you update the outgoing
messages table which says
post this message to the outgoing queue
that can happen as a transaction and
that can be guaranteed to either happen
together or not at all
and then on the outgoing table you would
have some kind of separate process
reading the outbox table picking up the
outbound messages and publishing them to
the outgoing queue now in this case you
are guaranteed in fact to either post
and update at the same time
or fail to do both at the same time but
you won't have an inconsistent system
does it is this practical and excel
question that you get a lot no it's not
really practical we don't do this
we have this use case latino system and
we specifically avoid using
transactional outboxes
because it limits you to using the kind
of data stores
which support transactions in our case
our scale is in the billions there is no
system which
uh can do transactions on end is fast
enough to actually serve as a cache or
or some kind of back end for us so in
our case uh we just update
we just post the message first then we
update the cache
and we live with the context
consequences of having a stale cache
and hopefully it will eventually get
consistent it's just a tradeoff we make
we understand the limitation of the
system
and we make it you know it's not a
surprise to us
uh we could do the reverse trades we
could try trade off we could update the
cache first
and then post the message and that would
have a different set of failure modes
and again that's a tradeoff would make
uh reasonably
right but the one pattern that we
actually do have quite a lot is
the saga pattern and so this is actually
a very common case let's say you have
a process in your system which has
multiple steps
and you want all those steps to
eventually happen or if some of them
fail you want to actually cancel
all the ones you've succeeded this is
extremely common again in our system
an event comes in and we have to update
a bunch of data stores and
spawn off a bunch of sub processors
which go and
create alerts send notifications do a
bunch of stuff and we want all of those
actually to succeed
eventually but actually it doesn't have
to happen immediately but eventually
they all have to succeed
or if some of them time out we stop
waiting for them we wanted to roll back
all the other things we did
right and so this is called a saga which
means uh because it doesn't happen in a
single database or even in
a simple system we have to take this
logical transaction and break it up into
a bunch of
steps and each service will serve a step
and then
we have to persist the context of where
we are in this logical transaction
together with the object that we're
moving from service to service
so let's take as an example your
standard uh
order service right an order comes in
from the website we have your order
object
and when the order happens we want to
pay some money we want to
update the uh the inventory if we want
to
call the shipping service and schedule
delivery now each one of those is
actually independent
but we do want to have to have all of
them happen or none of them happen
right because we don't want to send a
delivery if we didn't charge the
payment service and so there are two
ways to do this one is called
coordination where there's one service
which is
chosen as the coordinator and that
service has only the main logic of how
the transaction needs to happen
it will send one message to the order
service it will send one message to the
payment service it will send one message
to the shipment service
and it will expect a response back so in
this case we're using a
request response pattern it will send
separate messages to every subsystem it
will
get the results from all of them combine
them all together and then
our saga will be complete and at every
point we have a record of
where we are in the transaction if the
coordinator decides that
too much time has passed and we need to
roll back the saga it will send
the reverse message to the service for
example if you were if we already
scheduled a delivery it will send a
canceled delivery message to the
delivery service
but if we didn't do the payment it won't
have to cancel the payment
the other way to do this is called um
choreography which is
uh if you don't have a central
coordinator system
which does all of this you overload all
of the contact information on the
message itself
and so in our case we would send a
message to
the let's say the payment system and say
this
is a order do the payment bit the
payment system would do the payment
stuff attach the acknowledgement to the
payment was proceeded to the message
and send it on to the next service in in
the transaction
for example the inventory the inventory
service would update the inventory
overload the success success message on
the same message
to add to the context send it on to the
shipment service that would
create the shipment and when the
shipping succeeded the shipping service
will
again update the giant saga transaction
we have and
i don't know send it to the completion
of fulfillment terms right and so at any
point if one of those fails
it can send the transaction in the other
direction in what's called
a complimentary transaction so we'll
talk about this
uh a successful saga would be we'll
start you know t1
point transaction one and then end it
start next step start and end
the next step and then the final service
in the chain ends the saga
the downside of this is that every
service is tightly coupled to your
domain logic
right every service needs to know what
happens after it and what happens before
it if you want to rewire the order
because now there's a
fourth service in the middle you have to
change three components you have to
change the fourth service you're adding
and the two services on either side of
that because now they're need to be
aware of what happens before them what
happens after them
with the orchestrator the other the
opposite is true
right you don't have any domain logic in
each op sorry or any routing logic in
every service
but now we have a single point of
failure which kind of
isn't what we're going for in a
distributed system you have one service
which has to handle everything it has to
have all the acknowledgements
and it probably has to have state
because you can't store all of this
transaction information in memory
it forces the court the orchestra
service to have a database in some kind
of state
and that has scaling and performance
implications and so that's a tradeoff
you have to make for yourself
for most of our systems we go with
choreography which means every service
knows what needs to happen after it
if if it's part of a selection mainly
because we really want to avoid
bottlenecks
on the sort of orchestrating service
right and so if the attraction fails in
the middle
uh what happens is the service where it
fails has to go and create what's called
a complimentary transaction so if we
charge the person
we need to create a message which
reverses the charge
and send that in the other direction of
the transaction and if there's another
operation that needs to be cancelled
then the payment service needs to know
that part of the cancelling transaction
is to send a new message to the service
that came before it which is one
which is part of the reason why it's
actually complicated to do that
so towards the end of the talk i'm
actually going to skip over the
technologies
something google online there's a
million different message queues and
they all have
their pluses and minuses uh but what i
really want to talk about is back
pressure
back pressure is a very important
consideration for us
it's it's any system which has anytime
scale
will have this question of what happens
if a consumer service
cannot keep up with the producer service
right and so you have
two ways of handling back pressure which
means
the consumer service will need to tell
the producer to produce less
you know i think in a synchronous system
there's no back pressure it's inherent
right because the
the second service fails and then the
first service knows it that overloaded
but in an asymmetric system service b
can fail and the messages will continue
queuing up in the transport instantly
right and so we have two ways one is we
can have some kind of flow control which
means
service b the receiving service would
have a way
to tell the sending service to slow down
the main problem with that is it brings
us right back into synchronous territory
because that means that service a
becomes unavailable
at the same time or slightly after
service b becomes unavailable
uh our other choice of course is to not
throttle
or not do any kind of web pressure which
means the
queue or the message transport in
between the two services will continue
growing
until we either fix the problem with b
and in this case we have to
usually scale out b a lot more to handle
all the backlog of messages
or the message transfer fails there's no
right answer to this you have to figure
out what it is
that you need obviously the right answer
is don't have scaling problems scale out
uh automatically
uh but that's not always possible for
most cases
again this is a trailer for making our
system it will be a different set of
considerations for others for
every other system we almost always
choose the option on the right which is
we choose to grow the queue infinitely
and we allocate all of our message
transports
with huge buffers of free disk space to
queue up indefinitely
because we prefer to potentially
reprocess you know
two days worth of messages back uh than
to lose data but again that's because
losing data is the worst of the two
tradeoffs in our system
for the kind of product we have and for
different products that's going to be a
different
uh trade-off right but of course
basically the
it's like we talked at the start of the
talk uh
because of an asynchronous system we
convert any kind of failures
into lag into latency and when we have
lag we have to eventually consume all of
this lag
which means scaling out whatever it's
consuming
and again last thing before we finish
the talk uh error handling
uh again because unlike synchronous
systems where error handling is very
straightforward
you get the exception to the requester
or all the way up the chain
and you can handle it there because it's
coupled in time
with an asynchronous system the error
might happen an hour from now
it might happen on a specific component
so what do we do
let's imagine we have a queue of
messages we have to process all of them
and process b is doing the consuming it
will process message one message two and
it will then fail to process message
three
what does it do uh there are three
broad categories of error handling in
asynchronous message systems
one is they can continue retrying
message three forever
eventually it might happen if the
transient error if it's a timeout or
database
problem we can keep retrying until it
actually succeeds
this makes sense if you can confidently
identify that the error is transient
it's caused by something that's not the
problem is with the message itself the
problem is with an external component
and it will eventually go away and so
retrying on place is a strategy where it
makes sense if you know the error is
transient
um if you don't want to block the queue
if you think the
retrying is going to take too long you
can do what's called retry out of order
it means that you give up order of
delivery you take the message out of the
queue you put it in a different queue or
some other place
and then you have some kind of scheduler
to try that message again
and maybe then you will succeed but if
this in this case you can continue
processing the rest of the queue
and not cause a traffic jam so to speak
right you will want to lose throughput
the last option of course is a dead
letter q if you can't do anything with
the message
the problem is the message itself
there's no point in trying it there's
really nothing else you can do you have
to take it out of the queue you have to
put it somewhere else
usually called dlq a dead letter queue
and then
in most systems it's something that you
manually look at there's no automatic
system to handle dlq
uh because that's the final resting
place of messages you can deliver
um this is it uh
we're done exactly on time one minute
over thank you very much for your
attention i'm very happy to answer some
questions
i don't see anyone writing in the chat
in webex but let's see maybe someone
wrote something in slack
nobody wrote anything it's like you
people are very uh either
know more than me about this topic so
you have nothing to answer to question
about or you're very shy i'm not sure
whichever that is
but whatever the case may be i'm going
to hang out in slack
for a bit more so i'm happy to answer
questions
if you have any or you can see me typing
in slack and you can reach out to me
separately otherwise thank you very much
for coming to the talk hope you learned
something interesting today
an excellent rest of the conference
you